anyone who watches the flash knows that
messing with the timeline is never a
good idea but I never stopped Nora
west-allen from going back in time to
meet her parents the young speedster is
definitely up to something and fans are
dying to uncover the truth season five
of the flash is oozing with new material
giving fans a lot of theories to work
with keep watching to find out which
theory is keeping fans up at night the
flash season 5 took a short hiatus after
its fourteenth episode cause and excess
first aired on February 12th 2019
causing a whirlwind of speculations to
unravel season 5 is predicted to end
after its 22nd episode so we still have
a lot of time to speculate about the
grand finale season fours mystery girl
revealed that she was none other than
Barry and irises daughter from the
future leaving fans with their mouths
wide open with the way things ended in
episode 14 were led to believe that
Sherlock wells has found some mystifying
information in Nora's secret journal
Before we jump into some wild fan
theories let's take a look at some of
the Flash's upcoming episodes and tried
to decipher what they could mean for
Team flash why Nora isn't allowed in the
speedforce Nora has made it painfully
clear that she can't access the Speed
Force does anyone else think that's
weird when she initially tried to go
into the Speed Force with her dad it
totally backfired and it was soon
revealed that Nora had been reversing
time now that we know that Nora has been
working with Thawne aka the reverse
flash fans are starting to believe that
he has something to do with this he's
been withholding information from Nora
and playing her into her emotions so
although she thinks she's saving her
father in the long run she might be
doing the exact opposite tell me you
know what you're doing
cyber nerd er took to Reddit to post his
thrilling theory he's curious to find
out if Nora was actually born with
powers or if Thawne gave her powers and
convinced her that iris planted a
dampening chip into her when she was
young this would turn Nora against her
mother in a flash
so perhaps she's not allowed into the
Speed Force because she's not an actual
speedster fans weren't quick to point
out that the color of Nora's lightning
should entail that she received her
powers from Barry and iris however it's
on would definitely think of this and
make her lightning purple he's a genius
after all right Dawn's master plan while
we've got Thawne on the hot seat let's
dive right into what his master plan
might be
this theory is brought forth by redditor
may Lepke and his argument is pretty
convincing
Thawne has made it crystal clear that no
one understands timelines more than him
so he must have anticipated that sending
Nora back in time would cause cicada to
be introduced a few years early Thawne
convinced Nora to punch the satellite so
he must have known that her actions
would cause a ripple effect in the
timeline as a result oralin Dwyer became
cicada instead of David Hirsh which
totally confused team flash for a while
so it's possible that Thawne wants
Takeda to kill the flash for him after
all he's the only metahuman Barry was
never able to defeat it very where to
die or disappear at an earlier time Nora
would get erased from existence in the
blink of an eye the redditor also
pointed out that Nora seems to trust on
just like Barry once did of course back
then Barry believed on to be Harrison
wells and not the reverse flash however
Nora doesn't seem to know exactly who
she's dealing with either Thawne managed
to gain young Barry and Nora's Trust by
downplaying his dreams whereas he
convinced Barry he was in a wheelchair
he might be convincing Nora that he's in
jail hmm sounds like Zahn has a plan up
his sleeve
Nora's secret journal team flash welcome
Nora into the group with open arms well
Barry didn't at first but he eventually
warmed up to his future daughter but
there's one person who isn't buying her
story and that's Sherlock wells he's a
detective after all so he's bound
pick up on Norris strange behavior an
occasional slip-up Nora's been writing
in her journal and chatting with Sean on
a regular basis and let's just say that
Sherlock is on to her after some digging
around he decoded a portion of her diary
which translated to the timeline is
malleable
from then on he's been working on
decoding her secret journal and it looks
like he's made a discovery the last
thing we see in causin excess is that he
succeeded in decoding Nora's journal so
Willie forced Nora to come clean any
time soon or will Nora resort to drastic
measures to keep her secret to herself
so what if he confronts Nora and she
tells Thawne about it would he be able
to convince her to get rid of Sherlock
this could potentially cause Nora to
become a villain we'll do anything to
cover up her tracks but we're hoping
that she reveals all of her secrets
before it comes to that Godspeed fans
have been asking to see Godspeed flash
across their screens for quite a while
now and it looks like their dream is
about to come true
the flash is currently filming the rest
of season 5 in Vancouver set photos were
recently released and fans immediately
spotted out god speeds wicked costume so
they've taken to the Internet to post
some theories about the villain it's
said that god speed will make his first
debut in season 5 episode 18 this mighty
speedster might even be faster than
Barry himself which definitely poses a
problem god speeds real name is August
Hurst and he and Barry go way back in
fact Barry went to CCPD
school with August and the two were
quite close
if the CW chooses to follow the comics
August will become Barry's
crime-fighting partner unfortunately
after an explosion August will receive
speedster powers and turn evil while on
his quest to avenge his brother's death
Stan's believe that August is being
introduced in season 5 as a good guy
we'll need to turn in to season 6 is big
bad are you guys excited to see August
Hurst come into the picture let us know
in the comments below
Cisco will take the medic your're it's
hard to imagine the flash without the
hilarious Cisco Ramon no just me
he's witty he's smart and he comes up
with some pretty awesome superhero and
bill
but something has been a missin Cisco's
life for quite a while now and it has a
lot to do with his powers and his job
after being stabbed in the hand with
cicadas dagger Cisco began to lose his
powers and surprisingly he was pretty
happy about it it's no secret that actor
Carlos Valdes who plays Cisco has wanted
to take on new acting projects for a
while now so this could be his ticket
out of the flash on top of that it's
been announced that the metahuman cure
is ready to use which probably isn't a
coincidence
at the same time cisco has also met a
new love interest so fans suspect that
Ramon will use them at a human cure on
himself and opted for a regular life
this could give Barry
Ralph Nora and iris a chance to prove
just how smart they are fans are hoping
that Cisco will leave to start a new
life with Camila instead of getting
killed off but either way
Cisco most likely isn't making it into
season 6 why the flash goes missing ever
since Thawne
took over Harrison wells body he's been
trying to make one timeline come true
you know the one that says flash missing
vanishes in crisis
well according to Nora Barry does
disappear in 2024 and he's never heard
of again so it looks like Dawn's plan
worked out in the end
fans have been trying to piece together
the events that led to his disappearance
however decoding that riddle isn't as
easy as it may sound a Reddit user named
cats are not reptilians posted a theory
suggesting that Barry was going to get
sucked into the reverse Speed Force and
that it would serve as some sort of
prison it's possible that noir has been
using the reverse Speed Force to
time-travel and maybe it's about to
catch up to her another redditor wolf
Lonnie believes that Barry is destined
to sacrifice himself by zapping 2014
Barry as a thunderbolt giving him powers
to keep the timeline stable after the
crisis events what do you think about
this theory let us know if you think
it's legit Nora will erase herself from
the timeline it's a well-known fact that
Barry and iris grow up to have twins
Donald and Don so fans have been
speculating about whether or not Nora is
really their daughter while this would
be a shock they Karason Wells from the
pass believed Nora to be done so it's
safe to say that Nora and dawn could
pass as sisters therefore Nora is
definitely iris and Barry's daughter but
she might not be for long when Nora
first revealed herself as the Flash's
daughter she told her parents
I made a big big mistake
well redditor dr7 seems to think that
this mistake is erasing herself from the
timeline why else would the words time
is malleable be present in her journal
Nora's time meddling has definitely
changed the future in more ways than one
so is it possible that shall erase
herself from existence in order to
prevent her father from disappearing if
so it would make sense that Barry and
iris go on to have twins and refrain
from calling the girl Nora because well
Barry already named one of his daughters
after his mother Nora before you go let
us know which arrowverse character is
your favorite in the comments section
below give this video a big thumbs up if
you love the arrowverse be sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one we post new videos every
day
so hit that notification bell to stay up
to date thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]